what's up guys this episode is with john
woo of avalabs
in this conversation we talk about
bridging bitcoin to other ecosystems and
what all sorts of different tokenization
and where these other ecosystems are
actually going with the technology that
they're building i really enjoyed this
conversation with john i hope you guys
enjoy it as well don't forget that these
episodes are brought to you by ftx us
and you can click on the link in the
description to learn more let's get into
this episode with john john how are you
up how are you good to see you i think
it's about three or four years since
we've done this absolutely i'm doing
very well i'm glad to have you uh i'd
love to start the conversation uh we're
gonna kind of take a little windy road
here because i got a bunch of questions
um i keep hearing about bitcoin bridges
to avalanche what is that what are
people talking about when they say that
they are bringing their bitcoin to one
of these ecosystems
so
there's a basically when you're talking
about bridge you're talking about
different types of bridges but
basically you
enable people to bring assets over from
a different chain onto
you know one chain to chain number two
and allow the functionality that you
have on chain two that perhaps you may
have different experience from chain one
so there's a ethereum to avalanche
bridge that thing has generated over 60
billion dollars worth of assets moving
back and forth over time and now there
is a bitcoin bridge so people who want
to huddle bitcoin but use defy they have
the ability to do that through this
bridge
and when that happens like what is the
at a high level the technical uh kind of
uh mechanics of this is it bitcoin and
it's being wrapped in some other uh kind
of token is it literally bridging over
and there's like support uh for bitcoin
or whatever like how does that work
right so there's two different or three
different methods okay one way you're
describing is the wrapped concept where
you have it on one end and then you have
another one called the wrapped aversion
on the other end there's another way to
do it is really you can have you know
stuff on one side being locked but then
you have a native version of that on the
other end that acts as the same thing so
it's not necessarily any different
you're just minting a new
uh asset whether it's btc or whatever it
is there's two general ways of bridging
across one is the wrap like you talked
about and the other is actually just
locking the asset value on one end and
creating the same asset or a native
version of that asset on the other and
when that happens how much functionality
uh is gained or lost like it's
interesting to think about uh let's take
bitcoin as uh one example and then maybe
we'll use eth as another example so
bitcoin uh may not be as expressive or
kind of have as much of the smart
contract functionality uh as maybe an
eth has
when you see that do you lose or gain
functionality in either one of those
situations when you do these bridges
that's a great question and generally
speaking from the user's perspective you
are gaining more functionality
regardless whether it's the wrap version
or the native version to another chain
because you're doing that either because
one side is too cheap or too sorry sorry
too expensive you needed to transact
cheaper or there are different
applications on a different chain
um
so the user's perspective is you're not
losing functionality you do it because
you actually gain functionality where
you can't do it on the previous chain
from the um change perspective obviously
you increase activity and liquidity so
it's a it's kind of like a win-win the
you know the ones that are secure and
are able to do this well and have uh you
know assets that are you know secured to
the user will ultimately win in these
cases
got it and so when you think of uh kind
of avalanche why are people bridging
these assets over there what's like the
value proposition to doing that versus
like keeping bitcoin on the bitcoin
network or something
yeah i mean for bitcoin specifically
there there's less functionality but in
general especially avalanche's case you
know there's over a thousand
applications on the chain it's uh
instant finality it's super fast there's
lots of daps in d5 um as well as uh
gaming applications so just a lot of
utility and functionality for bitcoin
users who may want to keep their bitcoin
because they think the price is too low
but also get to use the functionality
associated with a
chain like avalanche so let's kind of
keep going down this rabbit hole because
it's actually pretty interesting to me
um
on bitcoin there would be two i would
say scaling solutions uh and this can be
super generalized right but there's like
layer two solutions like the lightning
network and then there's kind of side
chain things liquid and a bunch of
others um this is sounds like it's
almost like a third uh value proposition
that people would make is like hey you
could take the asset you could bridge it
either natively or kind of in a true
bridge in a wrapped way
and then you could gain speed efficiency
innovation whatever
do you see those as competitive to like
the layer twos and side chains or is it
just something that's different and kind
of just
two different questions there's like
side chains and layer two specific to
like you know lightning specific to
bitcoin and then there are layer twos
that exist in the call it you know evm
compatible type ecosystem um reality is
in the long run i think there's gonna be
a lot of interoperability among many
many different chains and that's really
where uh we all really deep down if you
are honest yourselves that's where we
want the space to go to
um layer twos you know they provide
certain functionality but they also
uh are not able to provide necessarily a
lot of decentralization and the security
that a a layer one can
but they do you know they're more
centralized so they can probably be
cheaper and faster in some respect so
there are different trade-offs but
over time i think it's about where the
community where the applications are and
there will be multiple winners and who
and then the interoperability is what
really the power of
the permissions world of blockchain that
we all want where people can actually
own their data and profit from their you
know data and have low switching costs
so over time there will be a few or
maybe more than a few winners but there
will be interoperability
and when you
look at that the interoperability
argument um there's people and i think
in every ecosystem that would say like
no we don't want interoperability you
know there's some sort of maximalist
view or whatever uh what's your kind of
vision of that interoperable world like
why do you say that that is what we want
well let's reduce this argument to the
most basic level like web 2 in my
opinion
scale we've all benefit from certain
efficiencies
but the infrastructure on certain level
operates
very poorly from interoperability it's
basically silo data basis monolithic
databases
everyone has to constantly update it
themselves you have to create apis and
permission who gets into where and what
and then you have to over time you have
to reconcile that so you have a
gazillion intermediaries and a lot of
middleware that's built and you allow a
lot of centralization and people who get
bigger have a lot of power over the
the uh the new entrance to anything so
over time what happens is like look at
swift network it's supposed to be
nonprofit but it takes five days for you
to send money from the us to an
international friend it's those
intermediaries and the painful
middleware
and uh other things related to that that
causes that delay so
if you have uh a permissionless world
whether it's seamless and chains out
there like avalanche that are instant
settlement instant finality payment uh
and settlement happens very close to
each other or at the same time and when
you have this decentralized public and
mutable type situation suddenly you're
unlocking trap value uh basically you
know look at the swift network or look
at credit cards what you're doing is you
have one counterparty to another waiting
basically for the validation that those
transactions are real and while it's
waiting for 30 days at the mur at the
bank for to pay the merchant at the
restaurant you are literally taking
money out of the system by having it in
a permissionless world where things can
move smoothly
and fast suddenly you are literally
making money more productive so
increasing the velocity of money and
effective actually even growing the
economy i mean you know gdp is money
supply times velocity of money
so when you start to look at other use
cases uh what else are you excited about
like where else is this technology going
so
obviously d5 is something that avalanche
is very excited about and if we look at
d5 2.0 when we come out of this call it
winter and we have spring
really excited about a couple of things
because for d5 to really explode and to
grow
you need new participants to come into
the ecosystem and that means tokenizing
real world assets and ultimately having
some sort of identity mechanism
on chain identity mechanism so that you
can really enable that
representation of a person or a thing
properly because if you look at d5 1.0
i think everyone in the crypto world
will agree that it actually the d5 apps
function pretty well given you know all
the stuff we hear from the c5 type
players
no one got their withdrawals halted
transactions continued code was the law
and it all happened sure was painful
these you know ave maker compound lost a
lot of tdl but they functioned and
everyone got their money in fact you
know it did pretty well in my opinion
however
the basic mechanisms to allow that were
the smart contract code you know rules
embedded into the code and the over
collateralization
so in d5 1.0 to get to d5 2.0 which we
all want which is to bring new users in
you can't use a system where you're over
collateralizing with existing crypto
assets that means just people who are
already in the system who have assets
are able to use the system no new
collateral comes in means no new people
coming in so in order to get new people
to come in you need less volatility in
that asset we try to deal with stable
coins in the crypto native but if you
tokenize real world assets that
inherently is less stable you also
invite new players in but to do that
especially with financial services firms
you need so some sort of proper kyc aml
and identity associated with it so we
are really excited for real world assets
that will be tokenized to grow the whole
d5 pi for everyone it seems like every
uh
kind of blockchain every ecosystem is
trying to do this so uh obviously uh the
ether and ethereum ecosystem photographs
a long time i've seen solana pitches uh
bitcoin with the tarot protocol built on
top of lightning avalanche et cetera
does it matter where stuff gets built uh
like you know if i use google i couldn't
tell you what the technical architecture
is i just know i type question in a box
and i get an answer uh and google you
know it's cool to me this answers my
question uh like is it ultimately gonna
is not the world we all wanna go to
where the underlying anything under the
hood is completely abstracted away um i
think actually the fun part right now is
trying to build and create and be one of
those players in order to do that but
yes the end result will be like your
stuff is served in aws you have no idea
whether it's aws azure or google cloud
and um
one day you just google it and you can
do it and you abstract away the entire
of everything under the hood when i
drive my car i could not fix the engine
but i know how to drive a car that's
literally where we want to get to but
right now it's a lot of fun and it does
matter a little bit right now because
there are differences in technology
differences in speed and scale and
differences in um value propositions so
i think in the long run or medium term
the ones that have better evaluation a
better value propositions will
ultimately win out but to the user in
the long run it doesn't really matter
abstract abstracted away and then what
about like institutions as they come
into this like are they looking at this
all just from like a speculation
standpoint are they trying to build
assets institutions let's define the
institutions i mean there are two types
of institutions there are like financial
services institutions kind of what we've
been talking about because of the d5 ben
but there's also you know just
enterprises or adidas nike whatever so
on the uh financial institutions you
know they're very aware that
the power of the blockchain or the
crypto
system is that when you need information
and money
to move at the same time
it blockchain is a very powerful tool
for that so
the
when you settle a stock there are so
many intermediaries when you we talked
about swift early there's so many
intermediaries credit cards there's so
many intermediaries and they're all
working off of their own respective
databases and lots of reconciliation has
to happen
a lot of the financial services players
are actually um
experimenting with blockchain the amount
of experimentation of blockchain and
development not just experimentation
innovation labs but the amount of
development whether it's jpm coin you
know monetary authority singapore with
dbs with jpm trying to tokenize
wholesale lending um
city doing the um custody recently
satgen you know working with maker dow
they are looking at it as a way the
technology as a way to create efficiency
and create more productivity and squeeze
costs out so that's one part of the
equation for institutions the other part
of institutions is really new business
models new business models that will
enhance user experience
brave uh brave browser for instance i
think you know it's been around for a
long time so i'm sure you know then your
audience knows it too but i think it's
kind of cool that
they protect you and your privacy they
don't allow your digital fingerprint or
your digital traversing of the internet
to just be sold you have to actually opt
into that so once you opt into that then
you can get paid in basic attention
tokens so you actually decide on your
privacy you then you own your data and
in other words like
tokenization and this whole new world
for institutions will change because the
users will now be at some point will be
able to basically turn their searching
into an asset via tokenization and and
get the choice of privacy or
monetization what are the risks with
some of this stuff like we talked about
bridging uh both rapping and native like
what are risks there and then what are
the risks of some of these newer
ecosystems
right so from the technology side
obviously there is you know
bad coding you know um and and
and things can happen with hackers
but
most of the risks we've seen have been
more in human nature and this is part of
the reason why the c5 protocols or c5
applications have seen more of these
problems than you have in d5 i'm not
saying that d5 there's no rug pulled or
anything but
when if you look at the blue chip ones
that are functioning they function
pretty well
the the risks are really on the human
nature side all of it i mean any c cell
will tell you you know human hygiene is
just as important to security as any
technology i mean look at all the the c5
stuff you know this is stuff that pop
you saw in traditional financial
services in oa we're talking about
re-hypothecation layering of dead
um unsecured lending and um basically
things that just happened to be
happening in crypto as opposed to
another asset class
and then when you start to
look into the marketplace you mentioned
the interoperability component of that
how would the market change if we got to
true interoperability like institutions
come in and they're agnostic to the
underlying like uh kind of
infrastructure or how does that work
great question i think right now they
definitely clearly are working more in a
permissioned fashion so they're creating
consortiums or they're you know
leveraging the blockchain for you know
their nodes are actually all part of
that bank just in different geography so
they're really leveraging more of the
underlying technology in a permissioned
manner however
they are slowly experimenting like stock
gen with the traditional d5 type
applications they want to test it out
ultimately they too want to reach more
people and so that is like on the comp
but again initially it's all about
productivity efficiencies and probably
doing more in a permission manner but
for institutions they need compliance
they need all these rules and
regulations so they need proof of
authority for the short term hopefully
in the long run we get to a point where
they will be more comfortable in the
technologies there and the rules are
there so that they can go into a
permissionless environment where
everyone can actually participate
so on the regulation side what are you
seeing there like what do you think has
to change what do you think is going to
change
well i think what's happened recently
for better or for worse has actually you
know created a little more urgency to
have more
uh
attention to the regulation of space
i think the
loomis gillibrand
bill has certain common sense things
that make sense like you know in terms
of you know taxing small transactions so
people can actually use
um
crypto in order to make transactions
happen without capital gains worries
there are but in general i think what
you have to do is somehow align
standards around the world because
you have different roles in different
geography different um regions and it's
really hard to put people on the same
plane if if you have to have a different
you know think of it as a passport entry
to every single place it's not going to
be truly global until you can do that
the benefit and that's part of the
reason why avalanche has the subnets you
know the subnets allow people to create
their own restrictions and then you can
toggle you know the lowest common error
denominator or the highest in order to
like figure out who can transact with
him so it's a some of the solution to
the to the lack of um
common set of rules ultimately i think
some global standards will have to come
about
what is the thing you're most excited
about in the next 12 months we obviously
are in kind of this bear market or
downtrend now uh what are you excited
about for people to kind of look forward
to
i wish i could give you specific names
but i am really excited about certain
big brand
traditional enterprises who are going to
be doing some cool stuff on avalanche
it's still that same theme of like real
world assets um
you know coming into this ecosystem and
growing the ecosystem for everyone so
um
both in the financial services side as
well as on the gaming side i mean
obviously we have a lot of visibility to
gaming as well because the subnets have
been really adopted by a lot of gamers
to to to basically create their own
execution environment in a very quick
manner so those are two areas that were
super excited i wish i can give you
specific names right now but the
audience just stay tuned and just follow
me on twitter or whatever and they'll
hear about it very shortly
and then lastly i guess is like talk to
me about uh the hiring uh environment
what are you all seeing there both i
guess in your own ecosystem uh and then
also in um
kind of other companies that you
interface with
yeah
so for us we're continuing to hire um
we're continue to grow
i will say it's probably gotten slightly
easier in the sense that a lot
we've come to the point where it's not
just high in crypto native people it
literally is hiring bd people from jp
morgan or goldman sachs it's also hiring
tech engineers from you know the silicon
valley titans that you know of um and
product guys from those places it was a
lot harder um just about four or five
months ago but now that there is um you
know a little more slack in the
employment market for tech workers
that's become easier
um from our perspective we're still very
selective but we are growing we've gone
from literally 10 people in the room
about 2.5 years ago to over 180 or
probably be over 200 in the very near
future
uh i lied i actually have a couple more
questions uh when we think about uh this
ecosystem we think about bitcoin we
think about kind of the entire space
self-custody is a huge piece of it uh we
do a bunch of work with ledger how do
you think about self-custody uh
especially when there's bridging when
there's uh rapping and there's like all
this like other things like how does
self-custody still fit into uh kind of
the uh the ecosystem
listen that is the holy grail i think
you know true people who people who
truly understand the power permission
list they want to own their assets own
their data and have switching costs to
the most minimum level as possible
this is part of the reason why ava labs
is creating the core wallet the core
wallet goes back to what you said
earlier it will abstract away a lot of
the stuff under the hood the bridging
you talked about um keeping one place
where you can keep your nfts as well as
your other assets having
like just a like normal like fidelity
type of experience where you can
actually do analysis on the stuff that
you own it's almost like an operating
system more than a wallet and it has
fiat or as well as uh
you know crypto on-ramp so it makes it
as if you can be a coin-based type
situation wallet but yet actually own
your own stuff have your own access to
it and that's what we're also you know
thank you for bringing it up very
excited about our own core wallet you
know originally came out because our
community wanted an experience that was
more um appropriate for the speed of
avalanche metamask is great but it was
built for a different chain and that
chain has different inherent differences
so the speed will be somewhat different
but
recognizing that the goal for all of us
is to grow the user base for the
ecosystem and to abstract away some of
the native crypto stuff so we can grow
that ecosystem that's what the core wall
it's all about the bridging and the and
all the other stuff that we just talked
about yeah all embedded and you won't
even know about it makes uh makes
complete sense where can we send people
to uh to find you on the internet
absolutely so me personally uh twitter
john the number one w u
um and then avalabs you know avalabs.org
awesome are you getting sleep
everyone always knows
not enough i mean i get my eighth grade
come on i see you every once in a while
last time i was on the show um we did
this in person now i know the zoom could
be deceiving but you look um pretty much
the same and by the way i just see the
advertising for eight sleep that's a
wonderful product it's awesome do you
have one
speaking of sleep i know incidentally
just pops up i don't have one but i had
a friend who had it and i stayed over
their place amazing it is a it's a
changer it makes uh i'm far more
comfortable it'll give you more deep and
run sleep that you need a lot of for
people
they're gonna hire you they need to hire
you
you can replace my it can replace my
whoop or aurora yeah you know that is
that is exactly what uh what it is
that's even better whooping or just tell
you
what you're doing this actually changes
so that you actually don't need them to
tell you're not getting enough sleep it
just gives you more sleep you you're a
sleep expert you're sleep we're sleeping
on you because you're uh you're an
expert at all this stuff do you have a
whoop or uh uh the aura ringer i do i do
have a whoop okay and the next step may
be uh eat sleep because that's such a
good experience on it yeah i am i use
the uh apple watch uh for most of it um
and uh i love the data i don't
necessarily i don't think i actually
like changed too much uh somebody asked
me recently like what is what do i do
differently in my life because of all
the like quantitative self stuff uh i
sleep on the a sleep right so i i
definitely know that i get better sleep
i feel better at higher energy all this
stuff and then on the apple watch uh
it's got all this data but you know what
the thing is that i do uh i just close
the rings like that like it's the most
basic thing right is i just try to close
the the activity rings to close the
rings like i'm good uh and how i did it
whatever like sure you know i might work
out i might go for a walk whatever but
as long as i close the rings then i feel
like i uh was active for the day and
it's such a basic user experience uh
thing of like there's these stupid
reasons you're on one end of the
spectrum i know a lot of other people
who become neurotic because they check
every single second you know i have an
apple watch too yeah i'm wearing um but
i don't use that for the sleep i use the
woof because i thought the loop app was
actually a little bit better for other
functions so anyway point is some people
get neurotic about it no i can't
actually is detrimental yeah i can't i
can't uh
i'd go crazy like i'd be sitting there
like oh i didn't close it yet like
just chill life um awesome job listen
thank you so much uh for uh for coming
on um i uh i think that um
absolutely thanks so much and we'll
definitely do together
future buddy all right everyone i really
hope that you enjoyed that episode i did
these episodes are brought to you by ftx
us you can go click on the link in the
description to learn more
ftx has super low trading fees sometimes
as much as 85 cheaper than any of their
competitors they also are introducing
digital stock trading to their
application what that means is you'll be
able to trade stocks right next to where
you trade cryptocurrencies those stocks
will come with no transaction fees and
no payment for order flow so you get
much better pricing
ftx continues to innovate in financial
markets and they are very quickly
becoming one of the most important
crypto exchanges in the world go check
them out by clicking on the link in the
description and go create an account at
ftx today hope you enjoy these
interviews we'll be back with more soon